hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of good news gaming the show
that highlights all the good and fun
stuff from the week in games just like a
miniature a our version of beat Sabre
it looks pretty messy though so it's a
good job that the creator is a pretty
considerate guy
[Music]
in the good news this week Tony Hawk pro
skater 1 & 2 getting remastered that's
it that's the story and there's no
better way to celebrate them with this
incredible tik tok you're gonna enjoy a
totally hot pro skater for the ps1 all
right you guys want to shred it I'm sure
we've all seen that incredible Unreal
Engine 5 tech demo it's getting us all
excited for next gen especially because
it was running on PlayStation 5 but
there was another piece of information
that came out of that whole Unreal event
that is just really really cool
Unreal Engine has been free to use for a
while now but developers would a 5
percent in royalties once the game made
$3,000 in a quarter but now developers
won't have to pay royalties to epic
games until their game hits 1 million
dollars in lifetime revenue that is
incredible and if the games revenue
drops under ten thousand dollars per
quarter the royalty reporting and
payments also stop this is a super cool
move that's gonna benefit so many
smaller studios good job epic this week
marked the 15th anniversary
I feel like the Cryptkeeper saying that
15th anniversary of Leroy Jenkins it is
maybe my favorite gaming meme and yes I
know it was staged but the timing in it
is comedic perfection the number crunch
the screaming of his own name the
absolute sounded defeat in goddamnit
Leroy it's perfect and I loved it as
much today as I did when I first saw it
on Warcraft movies calm there's a name I
haven't heard in a while
this is thirty two point three three
percent recurring of course chance that
I'm gonna spend the rest of my day
watching this with some chicken of
course
that Red Dead Redemption to is one of
those games that I am always always
thinking about replay it's it's going on
in the back of my head and playing
something else and I think but what if
you returned to read dead 2 and after
seeing this cool video from Red Dead
guides its back on my mind in a big way
by just changing the position of the
camera in Red Dead - they've made it
look like a completely different game it
looks like some kind of simulation game
something that's weirdly at the same
time completely new but also very very
familiar and then I also saw this video
of someone just petting their horse for
an hour in Red Dead 2 and yeah I found
it oddly comforting so I guess I'm gonna
start that download I said in an episode
a couple of weeks ago that I loved
watching people make things shout out to
our slash actors and videos and Chris RM
from the game so I just quote send me
this channel to check out and I've got
to say I'm now obsessed clay claimed on
YouTube makes these amazing pieces using
polymer clay and here he's made his
animal crossing island on a toilet roll
now when I was a kid and using polymer
clay I could make a snake there were so
many other cool creations like this I
guess diorama type thing of Ezio about
to perform a leap of faith and maybe my
favorite this recreation of classic
memes made just from clay and cardboard
Simon who hosts it has a super positive
and infectious attitude and honestly
I've lost quite a lot of time to this
channel so I am sharing it with all of
you thank you again Chris for sharing
with me serious business again from the
games for discord eme for an invite also
sent me this great news story from
wholesome games calm very in line with
what this show is a wholesome games is a
website dedicated to you guessed it
wholesome games per the website they
cover a genre of games which are less
concerned with how you play and more
concerned with how the games make you
feel which is really cool and an
emerging I would say genre of games over
the past few years so it's very cool
that they have this dedicated space
they're holding their first ever
wholesome direct on May 26th
at 10 a.m. PT and they're going to be
showing stuff from games like ooh bleats
skatebird and more so if you want to
check out some wholesome games
definitely take a look at the direct so
I've been trying to ease off Animal
Crossing just because I know that I
cover it every weekend so it had a
little mention up above with clay but I
saw this and it combines two of my
love's so I definitely have to include
it it this is incredible
terrace house this is Japanese reality
show that runs on Netflix over here and
it is such a wholesome watch
there's no dramas no yelling it's just
three men and three women living
together and trying to make something of
themselves get into relationships and
get jobs and progress in their careers
and such someone recreated the intro to
terrace house boys and girls in the city
which is my personal favorite season in
Animal Crossing and they also used the
theme song slowed down by lights follow
which is an absolute banger so this is
really ticking all the boxes for me but
if you're a terrace house fan Animal
Crossing fan definitely check this out I
love that we're getting to do these this
is a follow up to one of my favorite
stories we've ever covered on this show
you might remember a couple weeks ago
that amazing video of gh addict playing
through through the fire and flames on
Guitar Hero on expert at 165 percent
speed and getting 100 percent of all the
notes
well now dragon forces guitar player
Herman Lee has seen that video reacted
to it and tries to keep up on a real
guitar and it doesn't really go his way
I played guitar for a little bit okay
like it makes my fingers eight to look
at it and finally we're not above toilet
humor here and good news gaming what if
you needed to poop in resident evil one
[Applause]
alright that's it for this week as I
mentioned up above we have a GameSpot
discord DME on Twitter I met Lucy James
games for an invite that is a very
unconventional way about doing it but
we're not opening it up just yet we want
to make sure that we have you know the
right channels for everyone that there's
mod support in place and we want to make
sure that it's a nice wholesome space
for everyone to hang out in thank you
for watching remember the games what's
playful all event is coming up we're
going to be doing like not only all the
e3 conference stuff as you'd usually
expect with all the big announcements
but we're also gonna be streaming for
charity I'm helping to book all that so
we're getting some really cool guests
we'd love to see you there and obviously
everything is in support of copepod
relief all right
have a great week stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]